good morning everyone welcome to the
deans panel in the cities and the smart
cities research and education I'm Laurie
Weingarten interim provost and I'd like
to welcome you all to the panel today
we're going to be hearing from each of
our colleges and how they're supporting
Metro 21 and the smart cities initiative
at CMU first I'd like to thank Karen
Lightman who they're all right in front
and center executive director of Metro
21 for planning the event and inviting
us all to attend and I'd also like to
welcome each of our panelists that we
have here today we have Don Carter he's
a David Lewis director of urban design
and regional engagement of the remaking
cities Institute at Samuel Jim Garrett
is our Dean of the College of
Engineering next to him is ramaya
krishnan Dean of the Heinz College of
Information Systems in public policy
Richard shyness is next to him Dean of
the Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences and coming in right now
is perfect timing perfect timing Andrew
Moore Dean of the school of computer
science always always on the bleeding
edge okay all right so Metro 21 is a
campus-wide initiative and each of the
schools and colleges play a very
important role in shaping the future of
our smart cities work so the scope of
CMU smart cities expertise is very broad
and I think you're going to see that
today from assessing the impact on
culture on a climate change to
robotic-assisted traffic lights
predictive analytics of commercial
building fires or monitoring of energy
energy and infrastructure systems for
the Hazelwood green site and on and on
and on smart cities really exemplifies
the expertise of Carnegie Mellon and
that it's taking in are taking Rd from
the lab to the street so much alike how
we've been celebrating all the founders
of innovation at CMU in their fiftieth
anniversary the work that Metro 21
faculty have been doing and will
continue to do will have a meaningful
impact on our
community as well as our the broader
society so with that I'd like to I'm
gonna we're gonna open up the panel and
we're gonna do it in this way so we'll
allow each of our panelists to share a
little bit about projects that they're
working on in service of Metro 21s
mission of research develop and deploy
21st century solutions to the challenges
facing communities and then after that
we'll talk a little bit about the future
and then try to lead ample time for Q&A
so with that I'll turn it over to Dan
Carter to share a little bit about
what's what's going on in terms of
remaking cities well thank you Laurie
and I'm representing Dean Martin of the
College of Fine Arts where I was welcome
to nine years ago after 36 years of
private practice as an academic and
research colleague and I'm also a CMU
architecture grad so when I came here
nine years ago I kind of reentered the
ethos of Carnegie Mellon University that
was established by our founder Andrew
Carnegie two of the first buildings he
built were machinery Hall which is known
as hammer sloka Hall now and the College
of Fine Arts so why did he do that he
felt as engineers and the scientists
needed to have culture and knowledge of
humanities and art and he felt that
artists and musicians and creative
writing people should understand science
and that's been the very beginning of
what we do here every day and the other
ethos is we make things we do things
that actually happen in real life we
deploy things so in the College of Fine
Arts there are three centers I would say
of smart city research one is the School
of Architecture the School of Design and
my Institute the remaking cities
Institute School of Architecture
research very briefly focuses a lot on
smart buildings and smart energy and
that overlaps with some of the things
you'll hear from the other deans the
School of Design research they've
established a new field called
transition design in 2015 first one in
the world in which they're mapping and
visit visualizing
what they call wicked problems such as
climate change biodiversity and the
wealth gap both locally and globally now
my own Institute remaking cities
Institute just an example of a few
things we're doing we're working on
smart wayfinding and Oakland smart
streetlights for the city of Pittsburgh
smart technology and streets for PennDOT
including smart traffic signals and the
impact of autonomous vehicles 3d
visualization tools for urban design for
the Department of City Planning and
you'll hear more about that later from
Kristen Kurland and just this week with
Joe say Maura we put in a National
Science Foundation grant for data
analytics for predictive real-time
transportation planning in city of
Pittsburgh cranberry and McKees Rocks
three of these projects you just talked
about have actually been funded or
partially funded by Metro 21 now the
other point I'd like to make is the
remaking cities Institute in particular
where I work as an interdisciplinary
collaboration completely across the
campus was very interesting I first came
here and I wanted to work with somebody
in engineering and Computer Engineering
very top scientists and pre americium
and I was afraid to approach her because
she's so busy and I told her what I was
trying to do and I the metaphor I have
is I knocked on her door and I asked if
she wanted to join and she dragged me in
the door that's the way it is here so
I've collaborated with Heinz College
engineering and Computer Engineering the
scylab mobility research school computer
science robotics and retainment
Technology Center working virtual
reality and augmented reality a school
of design with wayfinding the School of
Drama you might wonder why were working
with the School of Drama well Cindy
Lamar o is one of the world's experts in
LED lighting technology and we needed to
know what the future of that might be in
terms of coloration and various things
and outside these walls we've worked
with pit
this University Center for social and
urban research and also the Pitt School
of Public Health so we're all about
collaboration interdisciplinary
transdisciplinary whatever it might be
and the last thing we were talk about
was education that was mostly about
research in addition to our
undergraduate and graduate programs
where we're teaching students we also
have a very strong K through 12 outreach
program in this region specially to
disadvantaged school districts and
children in which we're introducing them
to the field of architecture and urban
design and construction and the last
point I'd like to make about education
and research is how we combine them
together in the School of Architecture
for instance this 3d visualization
project we're doing for City Planning is
in parallel with a design studio we're
doing just in the spring using the tools
that we're developing in augmented
reality and virtual reality to the bomb
Center corridor so I'm very happy to be
here as part of CMU and also to be a
part of metro 21 thank you Thank You Don
it's and it has been a real pleasure
working with Don on so many of these
different projects that intersect
engineering and architecture and urban
remaking cities Institute
I'm Jim Garrett Dean of the College of
Engineering at Carnegie Mellon and first
of all let me say congratulate ROG again
it's a real pleasure for me to be seeing
this that launch of this institute
cities cities are made up of many
interacting systems of systems as was
talked about this morning that are
filled with people and so we we can
never forget the fact that you know
cities cities can't engineer out or I
shouldn't use that term in this context
they can't can't abstract out people
from from these systems and we have
infrastructure systems you know bridges
pipelines
[Music]
roadways that get you know covered with
landslides
we have mobility system subways and now
more and more autonomous vehicle systems
we have service providing systems which
is really where you get a lot of
interaction with with people parking
services and in this newest parking app
is a tremendous example of how you can
change people's lives for the better by
by providing a technology that provides
the flexibility that a human needs in
dealing with parking instead of having
to sit there and race out to the parking
meter you don't need to do that anymore
and but many times these systems do not
operate well and they affect citizen
quality of life I think that's what
metro 21 is all about is improving the
quality of life if citizens are spending
time doing something that they would
rather be spending time on the golf
course or spending time in the museum or
spending time you know with their family
but instead are in traffic are waiting
at the building permit approval line or
are waiting in traffic because of a
landslide
then the city isn't operating as well as
it could be in and in detracting from
the citizen quality of life so in
engineering we have a large amount of
research that's being conducted to aim
to improve the efficiency of these
different systems that are make up our
city we have work that's going on to
develop new types of sensors of all
different Elks we're developing new
networking solutions because as you put
more and more sensors out into the
environment and more computing on the
edge these devices here are having an
amazing effect of what can be collected
but we need to then have much better
networking solutions that are able to
collect that data in a secure and
reliable fashion we need to develop new
devices and services that take advantage
of this data rich environment that is is
becoming available and that we need to
develop models of these systems that
we're starting to automate as well as
the system of systems that's even where
it's more
critical to be able to understand what
are the implications and the
interactions of systems and how are they
going to affect the people in the in in
in the city I want to talk about three
specific activities and I apologize to
my colleagues in daily who I don't talk
about their activity they're just
there's a lot of activity going on in
the college first there's a smart
infrastructure Institute that is led by
Mary o Burgess and civil engineer civil
and environmental engineering and Bruno
Sanaa Polly in electrical and computer
engineering this has been a
long-standing collaboration in my
colleague Joe Zamora in the room here
and he and I were the earliest
co-leaders of this type of an activity
they are we that group is looking at
developing and deploying applications of
sensing and data analytics to the built
environment using accelerations
for example using accelerations from
collect that are collected from vehicles
that are moving over a bridge to be able
to understand what the underlying
condition of that bridge is in other
words using accelerometers that are
already on vehicles to collect data
about the underlying physical
infrastructure if we were able to do
that that's going to have a pretty
significant impact on on the data that
we have about all of our our physical
infrastructure using vehicle based
environmental sensors to be collecting
information about air quality of the
entire environment instead of just
relying on point sensors again it allows
for an equity of the understanding of
air quality across the city using
machine learning to disaggregate
electricity usage from just looking at
the main supply line if you can
understand how why different households
are using different greatly different
amounts of electricity you may be able
to provide advice about better energy
efficiencies and then finally the goals
of all these smart infrastructure
institute projects are to develop
data-driven models and decision support
tools that really help better manage
these physical infrastructures over time
to improve the quality of life of the
citizens of a city for the final thought
on this I want to leave
with his imagine if we could predict a
water main break prior to it happening
and go out and fix it instead of having
three times the amount of cost and
damage that happens to other ideas I
just want to talk about is we've
recently received a twenty seven million
dollar grant in called conics that's
supported by DARPA to develop that new
networking architecture for for Internet
of Things in smart cities and then
finally Raj had mentioned the two
University transportation centers I
won't go into more detail about that but
that is a lot of activity within the
Engineering College down the line so
good morning everybody
let me also offer my thanks and
congratulations to Raj and Karen and
Rick and everybody who's made this day
possible
you know if I were to take a step back
I'm the Dean of the Heinz College of
Information Systems and public policy
the genesis of the school beginnings of
the school was a school of urban and
public affairs in the late 60s with the
focus on cities so this is like you know
Back to the Future in a sense of
focusing on cities and this has been an
amazing journey over the last several
years in terms of having deep engagement
on problems with the city and the county
is testbed with all the folks that are
on the table but I'd like to sort of
highlight two sets of activities that in
particular embody what Heinz is about
and what its contributing to the metro
21 vision first and foremost the Heinz
College version and it is a center of
excellence on issues that are at the
intersection of people Public Policy and
technology so the first piece
particularly important here as Jim
mentioned in
remarks and the second is that we are
also the place that brings together
social science and an understanding of
people and their behaviors with data
science and decision science in the
context of these problems both in terms
of applying the the science to solving
problems but equally well pioneering
your methods driven by these problems
and our educational programs in
particular in the public policy programs
that combine technology and analytics I
mean we've been recognizes the best
analytics program in this space through
an award called the ups George D Schmitt
price are sort of an example of the
recognition that's been received now two
particular examples I think grant Olaf
and for those of you who are here in the
morning had a very wonderful speech
about how as we think about smart cities
we need to sort of think about equity
and deal with the issues of the people
who are being left behind and I think
the set of project activities that our
students engage and that our faculty
engage and that this is a particular
point of focus and differentiation and I
think the an example that I'd like to
offer there to one I think is a project
that sort of combines data and analytics
about the opioid crisis with methods
that have been developed here at the
Heinz College in partnership with our
partners both in the private and the
public sector which is really to look at
prescription data about people who are
consuming opioid drugs to try and
identify the trajectories of use of
these drugs such that you can intervene
early to identify those who are at risk
to determine who can be put into
programs that might actually help them
early rather than exposed after the kind
of recognition of the problem that
they're already deeply addicted to these
opioid drugs it turns out that the
addiction to opioids has multi
for societal consequences it has
consequences in terms of employment it
has consequences in terms of crime it
has consequences in terms of the use of
human services or public services along
a variety of dimensions so that example
in the small connects Public Safety to
Human Services to the use of technology
and analytics to really try and identify
solutions that might help people who are
deeply in need of this kind of help
which has these set of societal
implications the second example that I'd
like to offer and this has been actually
a great partnership between a there's a
new center that has announced about a
week ago here at the Heinz College the
block Center for technology and society
with a very generous gift from Keith
Locke an alum from Heinz a fifteen
million dollar gift and one of the
projects there has to do with dealing
with what's referred to as a spatial
mismatch between where people live and
where the jobs are so imagine if you're
in a disadvantaged community and you
live in Hazelwood but you'd like to
obtain access to jobs and in Cranberry
and public transportation doesn't quite
serve you because you might have to take
two buses and it takes an hour and a
half to get there however if you had
access to a ride hailing transportation
you could probably make it there in 25
minutes so one of the interesting
projects and this is a real partnership
between us
between metro 21 and and there's a
future of work center is really looking
at these kinds of mobility interventions
to look at the future of work and
finally I think the capacity to have
student energies and innovation come out
of these activities
it's want to give a shout out to Leah
Lisa Rhonda who's an alum from Heinz
who's created something called 4:12 food
rescue with a focus on food security
amazing ability to bring mobility and a
societal problem together so lots of
cool stuff to talk about thank you again
so I'm Richard shyness I'm the Dean of
the Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences but I learned a
different hat which is really why I'm
here which is the leader of the Simon
initiative which is named after herb
Simon and is an effort that really spans
all the colleges so I'm not sure they'll
be happy about this but I'm gonna
represent work going on in everybody's
College today yeah so um the focus of
this work is on really being smart about
applying technology and learning science
to education and I think that we all
would agree that in the future smart
cities and metro areas will need higher
quality education both for K through 16
and for the workforce because the needs
of the workforce are gonna change
rapidly and what we're gonna need to do
is develop very high quality education
that trains students from early early on
and is able to train workers to adapt
new jobs new demands in quick ways and
intelligently demonstrably effective
ways and so we found out many many
things from applying what we call
learning science research over the last
25 years and one of them that I think
has become almost dominant is that one
size doesn't fit all good education is
local and is adapted to not only the
context of the population you're trying
to educate but the actual individual
student right that you're trying to
actually educate feedback has to be
localized to what the student brings to
the table and where they're struggling
right and in order for us to produce
good learning outcomes we have to be
able to be smart about measuring what
the students doing what they know and
where they're struggling so um the
approach that we've developed and the
infrastructure that we're trying to
perfect and get out to the rest of the
world is called learning engineering and
the basic idea is to one develop some
kind of a cognitive model of what it is
you're trying to teach right so this
requires some cognitive psychologists to
go in and say what is the domain or
is the skill or what are the set of
concepts that we want the students or
the people doing the learning to
actually uptake and adopt and the second
stage is to align the activities of the
students do the help they get the
assessments we give them right to that
map of the expertise that the cognitive
psychologists have given them to as it
were align the instruction with the
thing to be taught and then to
instrument that instruction so that we
have very very fine-grained real-time
data about what the students are
actually doing what they're learning
what they're struggling with according
to that cognitive map of the skill and
then to use that data right for the
student themselves to adapt to what's
going on for the instructor right to
actually adapt to what the class is
doing for the course designer who's
designing the whole and enterprise and
for the learning science researcher to
say okay we have a way to progress not
understanding basically of how people
learn so what we're trying to do in the
assignment initiative is to develop an
approach and a set of technology that
will be usable by the outside to in some
sense fish as opposed to just build
courses and throw them over the fence
and let everybody have the educational
fish so that's really our mission to
build the approach and the
infrastructure to support others right
in developing educational approaches
that they know are importantly effective
and are locally adaptable to their own
context so we're encouraged we've had
lots of great success we built with this
approach an online course to teach intro
to statistics and in lots of contexts
it's been demonstrated to be twice as
fast and twice as effective twice as
much learning in half the time there's
been a bunch of cognitive tutors to
teach things like algebra and other
subjects that have now led to a spin-off
company and the number of students using
this all over the country is about five
to six hundred thousand every year and
finally let me just mention and there's
been a big rand study that has shown
that students who use this across all
socio-economic strata are gaining about
an extra year right in basic algebra
which is turning out to be incredibly
important and
the final thing I want to mention is
that using this approach one of the
faculty from robotics and LTI have been
developing a tablet app that teaches
basic reading basic writing basic math
and it's been submitted to the global
XPrize for learning and it's one of the
five finalists right that was announced
about a couple of months ago and that's
been for a gift of a million dollars and
now we're shooting for the grand prize
which will be a ten million dollar so
keep your fingers crossed so what are
the big challenges what we've found is
the most important challenges is
adoption institutions are incredibly
resistant to doing what it takes to
change their structures so they can
actually adopt this and we've been
trying to find ways to overcome that in
a lot of different strategies but the
most interesting one we're doing is we
actually hired an anthropologist to go
around to the basic meetings that are
happening about whether or not
Institutes heater or the departments
here are going to adopt it and we're
going to take those findings and
actually generalize them to other
contracts so there's a bunch more I I
can say that I've been given the signal
that it's time for me to stop that's how
I will just say we have ongoing efforts
for the cyma initiative here at Carnegie
Mellon and we also have efforts with the
Pittsburgh council if I hire a higher
education which is nine colleges in the
area and we also have a number of
efforts in the K through 12 community in
Pittsburgh way way more could be done
but what we're having what we have going
on I think is very exciting and
important for for the future of smart
cities
Chandru hi I'm Andrew Moore from the
school of computer science and I'm with
the relatively newest Dean on this on
this distinguished panel and I want to
begin by thanking two of these deans Jim
and Krishnan when I arrived to help run
the school of computer science I was
initially very concerned that we were
doing excellent work on almost every
aspects of horizontal technology but I
wasn't quite sure how were you going to
integrate that meaningfully into society
I landed here and one of the first
things that these these folks did was
take me out and tell me about this metro
twenty one thing which I'd been
oblivious about and it was wonderful to
see how much work was going across the
campus exactly on doing this pull of
here as a societal need to develop
technology towards it rather than the
push of here's a cool new thing where
can I use it so that was one of the
things which really meant a lot to me
when I started thank you for that
overall there's safely more than a
hundred projects on campus to do with
helping make the built environment there
stronger and better for our citizens I
wanted to just give you a sense of
what's going on in the sort of tech
parts of this world because it's very
interesting and I think it involves all
of us so at the moment primarily in big
logistics companies like Walmart and
Amazon and in some military roles you do
have parts of a campus or a series of
factories where you've got hundreds of
thousands of cameras pointing at
everything that's going on and often
that's used to do things like detects if
there are people who are picking up
boxes badly and injuring themselves or
if there's a security breach or if
someone's getting lost and so forth it's
a really exciting time to try putting
those networks of video cameras around
cities at a very large scale and it's
possible we have the almost have the
power to surveil a whole city
this leads to two questions which of
course are jumping into everyone's minds
right now like we're creating an
Orwellian dystopia and actually another
question which I apologize but is
equally important to me at the moment we
don't actually have the technology to do
this even if we were crazy enough to
want to the reason we don't have the
technology to do this is although again
thanks to Metro 21 we have a fantastic
experiment running at the moment with
hundreds of cameras on street lights
here optimizing intersections if you
want to do real processing on all of
that stuff you would have to take a rack
of computers remember a rack is like a
refrigerator with lots of boards in it
and scotch take one of those to each of
the streetlights in order to do that so
here's the first question
can we get the computing to be low
enough volume and actually low enough
power to do this so some of these big
high-level things we can do depend on us
solving that problem and there are I'm
very confident to say that Carnegie
Mellon mostly through work in ECE in the
school of computer science is ahead of
anyone else on that question and we're
finding that many large companies are
wanting to come work with us because of
it
second thing bandwidth that may not
physically be enough bandwidth for say
five million video cameras to actually
send all their information to a cloud we
don't know how to do that and
mathematically it looks unlikely that
you can do it but here's where it gets
interesting we almost never need to do
that if your cameras are smart what they
can start to do is watch a scene and
perhaps just send out images of the
stick figures cartoon stick figures of
the people wandering around a little
stick figures about the vehicles which
are moving around and a few other pieces
of information than that like that
furthermore in fact you know you don't
really care about the little stick
figures of people walking all the time
what
you really care about as if a traffic
light says or a or a camera says someone
who's tripped over or someone is in
trouble or in certain cases there's
there's a care hazard in the environment
so here's the interesting thing where
two groups of meeting it's we want to
actually do compute in the cameras so
that we're sending much less information
out and that seems possible to the final
piece which is really interesting and I
think I don't want to promise anything
but I think we've got a chance of doing
this properly folks who use this as an
opportunity to put encryption in the
cameras or on the streetlights so that's
the only information you can get out of
them is anonymized event information
like this so we so we're trying to kill
two birds with one stone how do we keep
privacy and how do we make it
computationally tractable and again I
don't want to promise anything but I
think if we actually get some kind of
reasonable solution to this issue of a
well Ian ISM versus goodness for a city
it's going to come out of this research
that's it
thank you thank you I want to throw it a
first question to the panel and then
we'll open it up so each of you needs to
talk about these activities they're
really going to define the future of our
cities but I want to flip the question
and say what should Metro 21 be doing to
both turbocharged what's happening now
and help to identify the next set of
problems issues to be addressed okay
thank you Laurie two things struck me
right away when you mentioned that one
is to continue to focus your funding on
interdisciplinary research number one
and number two
Rick Stanford's favorite term is
research development and deployment so
we're going to get something out of this
that can help the city the county or
individual people so it's
interdisciplinary research research
development and deployment but I wanted
to go to a different level I thought
that I've had
both from these panelists and from what
I heard earlier that was discussed which
what are the social impacts of smart
city technology what are the
environmental impacts what we call
triple bottom line accounting financial
social and environmental dealing with
the issues of social equity as well and
so what I would want to think about in
terms of a mission statement it's not
just about technology there's a famous
quote by William Shakespeare from one of
his plays is what is this what is the
city but the people so we have to
remember what we're doing with
technology what we're doing with
education whatever it might be it's
about people it's not about the machines
or the things these are these are the
mechanisms we make quality of life
better great thank you
I think I'm a firm believer that where
you are not going to have the kind of
impact that Metro 21 could have if we
don't have a true tripartite partnership
in other words the universities working
with the mayor's office or the chief or
the county executives office and his and
his and her or her staff to be able to
then work with companies that can in
fact deliver the scale we're not going
to be able to have any kind of a scale
to impact if we don't engage companies
that can can can work with us and then
implement it in the city context because
it's just not going to be possible to
just have the academic institutions and
in cities working alone as Don pointed
out we can have some tremendous
illustrative projects and things that
will move things along but we need to
have partners in Metro 21 so let me
build on what Jim said I think the the
biggest constraint I think has to do
with who's going to pay for all of this
and so at the idea of figuring out an
appropriate business model
is going to be quite critical and I
think the there are two two aspects to
this I think one is even even the the
success that Metro 21 has had to date
has relied on a really deep partnership
between federal dollars foundation
dollars the University and the private
sector working together on deployments
to demonstrate proof of concept taking
it from there
to an actual deployment in a world where
the buying agencies are siloed and see
their mandates so for instance
intelligence traffic lights
that's a transportation issue but
there's an air quality benefit as well
that's somebody else's issue so figuring
out how the incentives can be aligned
and what the public policy model might
be and what and this is something that
we're going to talk about later in a
panel so I'm plugging a panel that's
coming up so but figuring out the the
business model I think is is going to be
a key issue thank you so let me
reiterate what Jim Garrett said and then
expand on that I think that for what for
where I sit and what happens with
educational technology it's crucial that
there's some coordination between what
happens in the government what happens
in business and industry in what happens
in what we do because there's all sorts
of need and all sorts of demand that's
coming out of both sectors right that if
they don't have a way to get to us and
we don't have a way to get to them it's
a big opportunity loss so I think that
would be a big big help the second thing
I would mention is there's all this
great work going on with sensing and
with actually getting the data from the
sensing and getting something
interesting to come out of it so Krishna
I mentioned before that you know we have
all this data from phones and in fact
there was a project in Singapore that
was doing analytics on all the students
and where they were going and what they
were doing and what they were buying and
setter etcetera etc well we could take
that approach and that technology and
the analytics behind it and literally
bring it right into the domain I sit in
which is how to get the students right
to be better educated to have the
learning outcomes
amplified and better so I think a big
big help to us from smart cities Metro
21 would be coordinating and helping
leverage the technologies developed in
other areas so that we could get a hold
of them and use them in our areas I'm
pretty much on the same page with the
rest of the panel I'm interested in what
done you think of this small difference
I wonder if we'll focus relentlessly on
the use cases the things that we can do
and then we build backwards from that I
see CMU's key advantage is that we're a
very interdisciplinary disciplinary
place which helps us do that much more
effectively than other universities
Koff MIT uncuffed so that's good but the
absolute devastating number one goal is
use case and then interdisciplinarity is
our secret sauce which helps us get
there we don't want to organize a
project by beginning by saying we have
to have this set of diverse disciplines
involved thank you want to open up the
floor to any questions that people have
for the panel yes
and that's I think we you University
need to do a better job of getting the
citizen involved and if I look at the
Seattle and Chicago are both in some
sense ahead of us in this area Seattle
had a lot of problems because they were
friendly technologists sort of bring new
things which unwittingly freaked
everyone out in Chicago in general the
approach they took was much more to get
the community together to discuss what
they would like to see so I think we do
need to bring in all members of the
public for that and know what the rest
of the panel thinks to the Singapore
Center that Richard mentioned the living
analytics Center has a focus on smart
nation and the emphasis there is on
personalized and participative so there
are two parts one is the participation
the point that you made the other is
what is the incentive for them to
participate which has to do with
actually meeting a need that they have
so identifying and this goes to the
question of the use cases you know
identifying what needs they have and
being able to deliver to those needs be
they and within in traffic or be they in
terms of actually delivering Human
Services to them or dealing with public
safety I think that's critical
so it's both the personalization as well
as a participative Channel and one of
the things I think that smart cities is
going to really bring to the citizen is
access to honest data access to data
that will in fact inform citizens about
what is the situation you don't have to
rely on presentations of why we need
this public project you can actually
understand the data of where where the
challenges are and why this particular
piece of infrastructure might be needed
and that also points to another
challenge we have to start allowing
cities and individuals to own their data
and not let those who are sort of
creating the platforms to be the ones
that
are the data owners I think that that
will come out very clearly in the smart
cities that that's needed that citizens
are gonna need access to the data that
they are part of yeah I spent my whole
professional career dealing in citizen
engagement public participation at the
neighborhood level and other levels and
what I've been privileged to do here at
the University is how we can apply
technology to make it easier for
citizens to engage in the issues what
that might be and the one project I
mentioned already the 3d visualization
project are doing City Planning is how
we can explain to citizens what's going
to happen when a building appears or
disappears and and why we even engage
the entertainment Technology Center in
doing virtual reality so that people can
actually experience real time kind of a
fly through feeling what this neighbor
would be like differently in some way
and we're working with the school design
is how we can put that online and and so
these are pre this is pushing a lot of
the technology but it's all about again
dealing with people in an authentic way
that is open to everyone and transparent
everyone in the and this idea of
ownership of data versus big companies
and their platforms that's a whole
ethical issue that has to be dealt with
across the board with whatever we're
doing in smart cities I just add to that
two points one is really amplifying or
agreeing with Andrew on the importance
of use cases so in education in
particular right you know we'd give all
the students in K through 12 their
curriculum right there's a little more
choice in college and there's very very
little choice for the citizenry in terms
of what skills they might want to
actually get and learn as we're going
forward so it would be great to have
some mechanism for the citizens to get
to tell us like what skills they really
need to learn so we could go after those
and the second point Christian I'll just
whispered in my ear I'll be his
mouthpiece delivered in my colleges is
this technique that's being used and
more and more I think appreciated which
is called deliberative democracy right
which is a basic technique where you get
citizens
from all different areas randomly
constructed into groups right an issue
gets put in the table there's a panel of
experts right the citizens get to
deliberate they get to ask the experts
what are the basic facts right I guess
this was all premise on when there was
basic facts and and then what they
actually end up is is a forming an
opinion right which we can understand
that's based on understanding the views
of other people right and understanding
some of the facts some experts and that
is very very effective at sort of
getting an educated view and also can be
supported by technology so I love to see
that be amped up in the city here one
way to think about that if we just think
about what surrounds Carnegie Mellon one
way to think about the city is the
boundary of the city of Pittsburgh
another way to think about the city is
Allegheny County we had bridge
Fitzgerald here of course another way to
think about the city is the economic
region which let's call it southwestern
Pennsylvania
recent experience in political
observations have demonstrated that
there's a pretty substantial gap between
some of the counties that make up that
regional city and say the city of
Pittsburgh I wonder if you could comment
about how Metro 21 and Raj had a slide
on this earlier today should income
should define itself in terms of the
whole challenge of the region not just
the streetlights as Andrew pointed out
any comments on on how we approach that
because I think that's an interesting
challenge I just first of all I think
it's matter for Metro 21 to matter
priority first to make sure that you
don't try to immediately boil the ocean
I think we have to have we have to have
some use cases but one interesting use
case I had Rick was there's a lot of
attention on a times vehicles but in the
cities but you know one of the
challenges in rural communities is to
provide mass transit in an effective and
efficient manner to me exploring how the
concept of autonomous vehicles might in
fact be able to do
or a what-what is like a you know a mass
transit system but more efficient for
and affordable to me that's the kind of
a use case that I think metro 21 could
very easily take up it we just we need
to convene the partners the government
the companies and the university to take
it out I don't think there's anything
that would prevent metro 21 from
addressing something like that this is a
structure you actually put in place and
there's this wonderful course on
societal consequences of tech change
there the question that was posed to
autonomous vehicles and what the future
of the city was I could imagine a
similar sort of thing where you could
ask the same question of Green County or
a rural area and convene the
stakeholders it would be a different set
of stakeholders and I think it would go
to a question earlier that was asked
about you know participation and
personalization what would citizens in a
rural County really want to see and how
are theirs their problems going to be
dealt with via these kinds of
technologies so and having the design
school folks think about futuring
technology folks thinking about what are
the potential technological
opportunities for deployment and then
policy analysis being brought at the
table I think that would be a great way
to also do the convening that Jim spoke
about
so whether it's sewer systems whether
it's ridges whether roadways
these are facing potential blocks to
what extent in technology help sort of
educate policymakers and regulators as
to these potential events it may be
direct the appropriate dollars with a
civil engineer and the family speed
that's a great question that's a great
question
area and in fact it's it was the impetus
behind the creation of the smart
infrastructure Institute it was
recognizing that the infrastructure
grades continue to be if any of our kids
brought those that report card home we
would be pretty upset
it's but the plus at fast and in fact no
I sorry that the the best grade was C
for the bridge condition the the
challenge is again gathering the data
accurate and meaningful data about the
infrastructure so the the super
structures you can actually send people
on to look at now we're starting to use
more and more sensing to get better
information about the bridges but the
Buried infrastructure is where I think
there's the real uncertainty we don't
know what the state of a lot of our
buried infrastructures in and so I think
first we have to commit to recognizing
we we need to gather more information
about that that infrastructure and then
we have to realistically look at the
data and and and make decisions about
what are the highest priorities I was
not kidding about my dream is that we
get it's like a Minority Report for for
you know that movie Minority Report for
infrastructure where you get a report
that this water main is going to break
in
in another week and you can either spend
you know ten thousand dollars addressing
it now or you can spend a you know sixty
thousand dollars after it happens I
think anybody with presented with that
opportunity would take the $10,000
option if in fact the data is relatively
accurate in terms of its prediction and
I think we don't have that kind of
information right now
about our infrastructure in a way that
allows policymakers to to you know make
that kind of temporal decision but on
the other hand we do have a lot of
information about our infrastructure
that is is currently being ignored and I
think we need to solve the larger
problem about you know are we are we as
a community serious about having a first
you know first world infrastructure are
we going to be satisfied with a third
world infrastructure in fact I've been
in third world countries quote-unquote
they have a cement either better roads
than we do in something the other point
I would add is there's much talk about
again how do we pay for it so I think
this public-private partnerships that
have been talked about I think that's
going to be have to be a critical piece
of one educating policymakers like Jim
was talking about the other piece is
figuring out a viable model great I
think we're about out of time first
please join me in thanking our panelists
today
I think I think this will spur a lot of
additional conversation I'm I want to
say congratulations also to Raj to Rick
and to everybody who's been involved
with Karen and launching the Institute
as a way to make our community smarter
and more connected in all these
different ways so thank you all for
joining us for the panel I think you
it's lunchtime yeah
all right so they'll be outside and I
know you'll have an exciting rest of
your day so thank you very much
[Applause]